Well, we will get to Sixth
in 12 more jumps.
It feels unusual
that the fleet isn't interfering,
even discouraging.
I bet they're busy
with what happened on Fifth.
I saw your personal data
when the fleet got you in custody.
Sixth is your home planet, isn't it?
Is your body there as well?
-Nope.
-Then where is it?
It decomposed.
I was totally paralyzed after an accident.
They determined I was brain dead,
and I was gotten rid of on the spot.
Then when did you use Mind Trance
to get into your current body?
What? Are you interested?
-Stop with this and just tell me.
-Okay, okay.
The pilots of the Asteroid Speed race
copy their consciousness into the machine
and technically have two consciousnesses.
I'm the copy.
Oh, so you're
an emergency backup data?
Did you not have a human body
from the start?
I'm like a ghost.
I am Rick Ayer
and at the same time I'm not.
That's why your augmented reality avatar
isn't of flesh and blood.
This is my distinction.
Yeah, even if I'm like this, I still--
You still want to race?
And I still want to get with a woman.
Though you're a machine.
So, this is what you wanted to talk about
before we get to Sixth?
Tell me, Amanza...
am I alive?
Or am I a product of imagination?
To say the least,
you are here.
I'm here, huh?
That's a relief.